marlon's turn to their 2021
national league all-star representative
congratulations to trevor rogers he
makes his 17th start this year three and
two from rogers to taylor and his swing
and a miss
goes to the change-up for the first half
tonight well he's gonna have to be on
his game tonight
dodgers team very patient group but a
great change up on the 3-2
pitch two balls and two strikes to
turner
and a swing and a miss that time it's
the fastball two strikeouts in the first
inning for the all-star walker bueller
getting set
walker bueller beat kevin gausman and
the giants his last timeout just one
honor and run over six and two thirds
that was his ninth consecutive quality
start
home of the 2-2 to start his day with a
strikeout
home plate umpire mike muchlinski going
a little bit off of the outside corner
to ring up
chisholm
back to back k is for bueller that
rising fastball catching the outside
corner first to a lefty and now to a
righty
he swats this one to right center field
that'll dunk in for the first base into
the game for the dodgers
will smith with a one-out single
and another strikeout goes back to the
fastball he's got three
now we've seen some big numbers from
rogers tonight already
in his 17th start of the season talking
top tier velocity 95 plus
swain gonna miss strike three another
strikeout for
trevor rogers he's got four through two
[Applause]
and he can swing it walker mueller to
left center field
a lead off double
maybe he was miscasted as a pitcher on
the ballot
and that's how they remember them oh
that you know that great hitter i mean
pitcher
walker bueller one ball of no strikes to
chris taylor and the go-ahead run is at
third base
another one two and a fly ball to right
field and deep
over the head of duvall that'll more
than get the job done
tailored to second with an rbi double
and the dodgers have the first run of
the night
back to back doubles to lead off this
third taylor scores bueller
yeah something to go the other way at
the very least move them over now no one
from rogers he
lifts one to center field that'll drop
in base hit
taylor's headed for the plate marte's
throw is up the line and the dodgers
lead to nothing as turner drives in
taylor you know justin turner comes
through in his clutch quite often i
competed against this guy that's how
long he's been around and getting it
done at an incredibly high level
he's going to fall victim to the high
fastball 95 mile an hour basketball at
the top of the zone
so he hopes to make quick work of his
mound opponent here to start the third
yeah this should not take long whine to
the o2
breaking ball check swing he went around
enough and that is strike three so
bueller with his third strikeout and he
gets the first out on three pitches
what's he gonna bring on one two goes
back to the fastball and touches
97 for his fourth k back to back haze
dope in the third
well tying run to the plate here in the
third it's garrett cooper
three and two from bueller ground ball
through the right side of base hit
martay gets the green light he'll come
in to score and garrett cooper
makes this a 2-1 game now coupe does it
again
when you're hot you're hot and coop is
sizzling
now you get your best run producer at
the plate
cooper goes throw from smith is
off the mark and it's a stolen base for
garrett cooper as we talked about cooper
of the element of surprise in that
stolen base
garrett cooper tonight is playing in his
229th major league game
that was his first ever stolen base wow
three straight men have reached with two
outs marlins have a run with two outs
and now we'll see if miguel rojas can
tie this game or maybe even do more than
that
like we'll add one more base hit that
ties it up
miguel rojas in our bi single holly it's
like you've seen this before
maybe one too many times i don't know
now certainly you
start to learn everybody's game right
that's what mickey row does best
it's been a big third inning two for the
dodgers in the top two for the marlin so
far in the bottom
and a ground ball up the middle
mckinstry
low throw and it gets away from pools
here comes ball
he'll score on a ground ball the second
base the marlins get a break and take
the lead
[Applause]
of course you don't factor in the error
that happens and maybe you're not
trailing in this one
very true dodgers had the shift on and
really nobody on the left side of the
infield so panic drops down the bunt to
lead it off
runner goes little butcher boy and the
ball gets away
panic up and he'll race over to third
panic was off with the pitch
rogers square pulled it back and then
the throw got away from lux at
second who's slow to get up over there
home run type cuts in both of his first
two at bats in this game
up the middle face it for jazz pinnacle
score and the marlins have a 4-2 lead
middle of the field holly and he gets
the job done yeah it's a great swing and
i think this swing happens because he
laid off the cut fastball
on the 2-0 pitch
another strikeout for rogers goes to the
changeup
and he gets number seven 94th pitch
is a strikeout another
one on the changeup 8k for rogers
he's done a fantastic job over the last
few innings
of setting his change up up
and barnes with a base hit to left
center field
and a little bit of a stumble but the
ball gets by sanchez and barnes is at
second with one gone
so another pin [ __ ] base hit for austin
barnes getting the tying run to the
plate here in the seven
matingly coming out as chris taylor gets
ready to hit looks like that's going to
be
against a new pitcher in a 4-2 game here
in the seventh
on a payoff he takes ball four the tying
run reaches here in the seventh
two strikes two outs and two on here
comes from pop
swing and a miss for strike three
dials up 96 to get turner
[Applause]
[Music]
for the dodgers jazz flying out of the
box mckinstry
just about in the right field bullpen
making that play
this is what we talk about the number
one reason
you hear me marlon's fans talk about
contact with jazz that was his fastest
sprint speed of the year according to
statcast
chopper to third turner scotty goes to
second one mckinstry fires the first for
an indian ending double play
or if you're just albert you're like
listen i just doesn't matter slider
fastball i
i just know how to hit fleet off hit
albert pujols now a 3-2 pitch to will
smith
all four and the tying run is a board
with nobody out
pops 3-0 once he watches ball four to
load the bases
here they come and don mattingly will
come out
and get the ball from zach pop hess
coming in for his marlin's debut
he inherits a bases loaded no out
situation
right now got to focus on gavin lux on a
3-1
lux takes ball four and it's a one-run
game
bases loaded walk for lux picks up an
rbi
in comes beatty up comes bellinger still
nobody out
and now the tying run 90 feet away
and nobody out and cody bellinger coming
up
to hit for zach mckinstry that is a high
drive to right center field
marte's going back at the track at the
wall
just enough room but bellinger has tied
the game with a sacrifice fly as smith
steps on home
not only does he tie the game but he
hits it deep enough
very least to get the runner over from
second to third the go ahead
run over to third base
four pitch walk bases loaded again
oh two from hence strike three
tess strikes him out to leave him loaded
and with
two outs that'll bring up jorie alfaro
alfaro line drive left center field hit
well
carrying gone home
and it gives the marlins the lead in the
bottom
[Applause]
and the marlins have taken the lead back
it's 5-4 in the eighth
the dodgers were no hit a week and a
half ago
they have not lost a game since
outscoring opponents
48 to 19 during the win streak but the
marlins in front by a run
in the ninth one and two from bender
muncie pops this one up birdie is
underneath it
it's a marlins win
the win streak comes to an end at nine
for the dodgers the marlins bounce
back